foreign
[Music]
let's play E4
okay and we know what we're doing
in response to C5 we play A Smith Mora
C takes D4 and C3 hopefully the
smithmore Gambit is accepted and it is
very good
we continue our journey in the Smith
Mora Knight C6 Knight F3
all right C6 Knight F3
and G6
okay so G6 is one of several possible
moves here
I don't think it's supposed to be the
best move I actually don't even think
it's supposed to be
all that good if I remember correctly we
are going to play Bishop C4 as is the
custom in these positions but light
squared Bishop always goes to C4 and
Bishop G7 to buy black so from a
conceptual perspective fianchettoing the
bishop is completely understandable like
that is the gold standard for black
setup but in the Smith Mora developing
quickly is more important than
developing
in a high quality fashion yeah here are
the move of Z5 you guys are
demonstrating excellent knowledge of the
opening we had a game like this so I
remember checking Mark's book I remember
that the move here is actually E4 E5 if
you don't know this and this is why an
opening like the smithmore has to be
studied carefully before you play it if
you don't know what to do here you would
probably end up castling you would
probably end up castling or you would
play a move like Queen to D5 which I
know some of you are probably tempted by
Queen to D5 doesn't do anything on
account of E6
if you Castle then you're giving black
an opportunity to push the d-pawn up to
D6
now is that the end of the world
absolutely not but it immobilizes the E4
Pawn so Mark's move is the immediate E5
Pawn push which already causes
significant problems to Black why is
this such a good move well the idea of
this move
should be pretty obvious you're
preventing black from developing their
Knight to F6 and if Knight takes C5
then we play Knight takes C5 Bishop
takes E5 and there's a sack on F7 that a
lot of you are familiar with
Knight H6 I don't know
Knight H6 I do not know so I am on my
own here
um
well
I'm on my own here and there's sort of
two candidate moves that
come to mind here
we can castle and we can absolutely
Castle here there's nothing wrong with
that but I'm a little bit concerned
about the welfare of this E5 Pawn
and ideally I would like to arrange my
pieces in such a way that I'm not at
risk of losing the E5 Pawn so what
bothers me about castling here is the
move Knight G4
we definitely don't want to take the
Knight on H6 right because our dark
squared Bishop is a valuable asset we
don't want to exchange it for a you know
for a crappy night on the side of the
board
so the move that really catches my eye
here is actually Bishop to F4
and you might look at this and say well
you know it doesn't look like such a
sexy developing you know development
square but I think it's important to
over protect the E5 Pawn so that black
doesn't play Knight G4 and and win the
pawn if black can win the pawn will end
up in trouble now I think we can very
safely castle and our opponent is still
playing instantly so I'm
a little bit on high alert
but I don't see a problem with just
castling
okay D6
yeah so our opponent gives away gives
the pawn back in order to accelerate the
development of his or her light squared
Bishop
maybe we've already misplated I don't
know but White's move here seems to be
basically forced I mean we have to take
the Bonnet I don't see anything else
perhaps some of you would be attracted
by them of Queen D2
but I don't think Queen E2 gives that
much
and queen D2 Knight F5 or queen D2
Knight G4 you're actually sending the
Knight
to a square that wants to go anyway
which is something that you want to
avoid
okay e takes D6
Knight F5 wow I mean fairly this is
still Theory I I don't know this at all
but this looks quite reasonable for
black
okay so now the pawn on D6 is attacked
we have to do something with it I I
don't see an alternative to D takes E7
let's do it
and we get a kind of interesting
position with an open Center I'm known
in you know my
career as a chess player as somebody who
it tends to be pretty good at open
Center positions these are my favorite
types of positions where there are no
Pawns in the center and what does it
mean what implications does an open
Center position have well it basically
means there's a ton of tactics because
the board is wide open the Central files
are open you know you can put your
pieces anywhere you want in the center
um and these positions are very hard to
handle because what always happens is
that there's a ton of candidate moves
there's some attempting moves and you
don't know which one to play so let's
try to sort through the complications
here okay well
to me the most obvious move is rookie
one attacking the queen where is the
queen going to go if we play rookie one
well it's probably going to go to C5 in
order to attack this bishop
and so we could definitely play rookie
one Queen C5 and then drop the bishop
back to B3 that looks absolutely normal
what other moves do we have in mind well
the move Knight D5 comes to mind
centralizing the Knight
D5 probably black will still play the
move Queen C5
um perhaps even black will play the move
Queen to E4
sticking the queen in the center and
attacking this bishop
but there's an interesting line that I'm
already seeing there
no Knight D5 Queen E4 does seem fine for
black
so I I agree that this move kind of
overextends White's pieces a little bit
I don't I don't particularly love Knight
D5 I'm not married to that concept
I actually like rookie1 I think it's I
think it's simple
rookie one there is Queen before though
that's a weird little move oh and then
we can play rookie four no but then
Queen takes B2 man
apparently this line is fine for black
okay rookie one Queen before we'll play
Queen B3 we'll go into an end game
let's go Ricky one
let's go rookie one wow
okay I I would be suspicious if this
wasn't still Theory
so this attacks the bishop if the bishop
moves then we lose the other Bishop I
think our move is absolutely forced we
need to play Queen B3
because we we should avoid losing the B2
Pawn
we'll check the database
um we'll check the database after the
game but finally we got him to think
we got our opponent to think why am I
going to this end game why do I think
that white has chances for an advantage
in the end game well the main reason
that I think white is probably slightly
to be preferred has to do with the
placement of the pieces which of White's
pieces is more actively placed than its
black counterpart who can tell me what
is like the nature of our peace
placement superiority
it's the light squared Bishop right if
we were to isolate the reason that I
like White's position it's because this
bishop is controlling an important
diagonal and this bishop still has yet
to be developed which way should we take
the queen an instructive moment you
should you're watching on YouTube you
should pause the video and think about
this which way to take the queen
to me the answer is kind of a no-brainer
to me the answer is kind of although
I think both recaptures are okay but my
intuition is screaming actually to take
with the pawn
Maybe I'm Wrong
let's investigate the why is my
intuition screaming that because largely
taking with the pawn does two things it
opens up the a file which is always good
and it secures the bishop on C4
taking back with the bishop I feel like
potentially allows black to stick a
knight on D4 with tempo
and I want to create a bit of an
imbalance on the board I wanna I wanna
add some Tabasco sauce to the position
so let's take back with the pun I'm a
lot less worried about the pawns being
doubled if you've watched my speeder on
consistently you know that there are
certain things that I prioritize over
other things and one of the things that
I almost always de-prioritize uh are our
past pawns they're usually not that
important Knight fd4
okay so I think that here we should
probably take the Knight
we should probably take once
okay so so the threat is to play Knight
C2
I'm positive that many of you are
attempted by the move Bishop to D6 here
but if we calculate this out Bishop D6
Rook d8
um Bishop D6 Rook d8
sorry doubled pawns I meant I I might
have said past spawns Bishop D6 Rook d8
Bishop B7
Rook E8 and 95 Knight C2 Knight F6
Bishop takes F6 now it doesn't work I'll
show you after the game the line I just
calculated
what else can we do
yeah rookie seven
I think rookie seven is natural and
pretty strong
because we are um
while we're sticking a rook
on the seventh rank
now when you do such a thing you have to
make sure that your opponent
cannot Chase The Rook away from the
seventh rank
and in this case black can but it's not
that simple
well if Knight C6 I wanted to play Rook
C7
and is the rook in a bit of danger there
yeah but you know what is fun about life
if we're not Living Dangerously
we're obviously trying to get the other
Rook into the game and you know
sit on black before he can complete his
development
but I there is something I missed here I
miss the detail let's see if our
opponent finds it
Bishop pep six found wow okay
very strong
so what did I miss I'm losing the touch
and the speedrun I missed that after
Rook C7 there's this retreating with
Bishop d8
yeah I missed I missed Bishop F6 Rook C7
Bishop d8
okay well we need to improvise but I
just found a beautiful idea I just found
a super sexy idea
I just found a super sexy idea let's see
who can find it
ah this is a good this is a this is a
nice move
Knight D5 very good yeah 1995
95 because if Bishop E7 the Knight takes
C7 check King moves Bishop E5 check
picks off the Knight on
D4
so how do I find this move right you
might be looking at the signal I get the
reason you know I can understand this
move after it's played but how would I
found this move during the game well it
all has to do with not making
assumptions right the reason that a move
like this is hard to find is because
you're automatically assuming that you
have to move the Rook once you free
yourself from that assumption
it becomes possible to find these types
of moves what else did I consider I
thought about maybe bishop D6 here well
that doesn't work because black takes it
and goes rookie eight thought about
maybe just sacking it positionally going
to Rook 81 but once you start thinking
in that direction ultimately you spot
the move Knight D5 because you recapture
with a check
does that make sense
so you know you have to avoid making
these immediate blanket assumptions that
oh I have to move the Rook I have to do
this keep an open mind to tactics even
in the end game and you will find
yourself
spotting more of these types of
unexpected tactical moves
but you have to be patient with yourself
and it's also the product of just
solving a ton of puzzles
I think black is in a serious amount of
trouble here because the bishop is
hanging
and it's not easy to defend it I think
like does have a defensive move here but
I don't see anything truly satisfactory
I think black is worse everywhere
yeah free yourself from these
assumptions and then hang pieces and
said Daniel said
to not make assumptions in you know when
their pieces are hanging I I really
think that black has only one move let's
see if black finds it
okay Knight C6 well that's not it that's
obviously not it that's just loses on
the spot
yeah and you can still see that that
people when they're faced with these
types of challenges they'd end up panic
immediately like this just gives up the
bishop with a check yeah this of course
is Black's idea but it has not a single
chance of working in fact I think there
is more than one refutation so the
simplest the absolute simplest move here
is to drop the Knight back to D5
and then after Knight takes C7 Knight
takes C7 we have two pieces for our rook
and we should be winning but there is a
much better and much simpler move which
is of course Knight E8 check and this
ends the game
because either black has to move the
king or take the Knight and lose a rook
yeah Marca
Mark's opening prevails again but
although this was a short game
we have a lot to discuss in the opening
and there's a lot of meat on the bone in
the middle game
last couple of games have been pretty
short I guess
so
yeah so the G6 variation I think we
faced it once before Bishop C4 Bishop G7
and E5
okay so Knight H6 is the move that I
didn't know it is the main move
um Bishop F4 is indeed the the database
move Bishop F4 castles castles D6 there
is one game in the database here still
so we're just gonna have to check with
the engine
we're just gonna have to check the
opening with the engine and notice that
you might say well isn't that doesn't
that violate the spirit of the speedrun
well
I always tell this to students the best
like use case for the engine is in the
opening right if you want to determine
whether you played correctly in the
opening you have two options you can use
a book if you have a book on the opening
but if you want to check efficiently and
quickly you can pull up the engine and
check it'll give you a good sense of
like whether you played uh you found
moves in the right ballpark right so
hopefully you can forgive me for pulling
up the engine this early in the game or
early in the analysis rather but the
logic hopefully makes sense so
G6 Bishop C4 so E5
let's wait for the engine to load E5
isn't actually the top move
are we sure that E5 is the move
because I remembered it from Mark's book
yeah E5 does okay on on when you give it
more time it seems to like you five more
so Knight H6 Bishop F4 is actually not
the top move
but it's a pretty low depth
it's a pretty low let me let me do a
depth 24 depth 20 is decent
yeah so interestingly he wants us to
Castle the downside of playing Bishop F4
immediately is that there is the
immediate move D6 apparently
yeah I'll show the Knight takes C5 line
in a second don't worry
so anyways Bishop F4 Castle's castles D6
yeah takes Knight F5
yeah D is the top move
okay Knight D5 is the top move oh
twist plot twist and rookie one is the
second move so okay we didn't play too
badly here
but apparently this is the top move and
I was worried about this response oh
there's Knight D2
retreating move attacking and defending
and the queen just starts to get I mean
it's just that black is in trouble here
because White's pieces are so active
and The Rook is coming to E4
no you want to be very careful a lot of
people in the chat are suggesting the
move G4
in such positions with a wide open
Center you want to be so careful about
moves like G4 they're incredibly
weakening and they could hurt you in
ways that you don't realize
um look at how harmonious white species
are and like oh but isn't the pawn
hanging yeah but big whoop right you
just go Rook B1 is this Pawn gonna make
or break you know it's not gonna break
the bank
Queen A3 and now the engine gives Knight
E4 I mean just the concentration of
white spaces in the center is what
causes lots of trouble for black because
the Knight is heading to F6
and uh yeah somebody like Paul morphy
would just like kill for a position like
this so anyways I just wanted to show
the lines after Knight takes E5
uh because there are some cool lines
here
um I I might have shown this before in a
speed run
so if I remember correctly it's 95
Bishop D5 let me grab Mark's book
the Bible the smithmore Bible
Knight takes E5 okay so
um Knight H6 interesting Mark Mark
actually gives Knight H6 Castle's
Castle's Bishop F4 D60 D
Etna Queen D2
so the main line is indeed Knight takes
E5
so we take take and Bishop F7 Queen D5
question mark
dubious fails the bishop C3 check BC E6
Queen D6
and Black's extra material outweighs his
odorous dark squares a good word and
lagging development
um black plays 97 and Knight F5 and
pushes White's Pieces away from the dark
squares so you're supposed to take on F7
here
Queen D5 check
King G7 bucks
sorry Box means only move
yeah King F6 obviously there is like
Bishop G5 check
that's a nice move by the way look at
that move Bishop G5
King G5
Fork
and if I don't even I won't even talk
about King F5 and this is
this is a box so when I say A Move box
it means only move and that comes from
the old chess informants
uh so chess informants were basically
for the younger members of the chat and
and for the YouTube video
uh chess informant was a collection of
games that was released in the
pre-computer era how would you get your
top level games in the pre-computer era
informants would be released a couple of
times a year it was like a thick book
and it wasn't just the games it was
games that were sent by the players
themselves who also annotated those
games and the point of the informant was
to make it readable across all languages
so they basically tried to eliminate
words and they therefore developed a
system for for indicating various things
so only move had the indication bucks
you can do that on chess space too
uh there were all these symbols like
Arrow that's where Arrow comes from
Arrow to the side means attack arrows
straight up means initiative
there's a symbol for zugsvong oh like
tons of symbols
so informants still come out but they're
like dying it's like people just don't
use them anymore because everything's
online they they've been dying out for
for years now
I even sent some games in to the
informant like 2011.
yeah exactly that box means only move so
informally Yasser says this you could
just say King G7 bucks King G7 only move
that doesn't lose
Queen E5 Knight F6
and castles short
and Mark continues D6 Queen E2 novelty
my over the board inspiration
Bishop F5 Bishop E3 I'm just going down
Mark's Main Line rookie one Rook fe1
Ricky Rick if you want to work C8
Rook a D1
white continues with a simple yet
effective plan
only now does the computer begin to
appreciate that black is no constructive
way to improve his position
yeah look at White's pieces look at
White's pieces look at how bad Black's
King is just like all these weak squares
and white is super harmonious amazing
compensation for the pawn
no the purposes I just explained is to
make it universally readable
across all languages as far as I know
so that's a bit of the line with Bishop
takes F7 check
and now we get to the rest of the game
so Queen B3
Queen b3ab Knight fd4 is an excellent
move and as you can see the engine
evaluates both moves approximately the
same but I think it takes B3 has a
little bit more meat on the bone
as a little bit more meat on the bone
so the top engine move here
is I wouldn't say it's unfindable it's
definitely findable but it's very very
difficult
Bishop E6
isn't that a free Pawn well if you look
carefully you should see that after Fe
the f file opens up what's on the file
it's a bishop what can we say about the
bishop it's undefended and The Rook on
E6 is also vulnerable so Knight fd4 is
super unpleasant take it take it rookie
four
now fortunately this tactic doesn't
exist because the Knight defends E2
otherwise black would be winning a piece
but you can recapture the pawn
with uh sorry with approximately an
equal position as you can see
so difficult difficult move you have to
calculate quite a bit but Knight fd4 is
also fine according to the engine takes
takes rookie seven top move
and even though this is where you have
to be careful about using the engine I
already think that practically speaking
Knight ft4 is an inaccuracy I think
Bishop E6 is the most practical move
this position is already difficult to
play for black look at the engine's Top
Line
look at the engine first of all H5 and
who's gonna play that move and I don't
even agree with it I think the engine's
gonna
reconsider 96 is the top move
we would have taken
now you're supposed to just give away a
pawn
and play A5 how do you know that this is
equal I mean white is up a pawn you can
go after the other Pawn I would imagine
that white has some winning chances here
and you can see that the computer starts
to give white a tiny pull here
um so this is already a point at which
black has to tread very very carefully
because this Rook is such a bone in
Black's throat a lot of you were worried
about Knight C6 but here The Rook slides
into C7 and it's surprisingly difficult
to attack The Rook
and after Bishop F6 Knight D5 already
it's very bad but I was right I think
the only way for black to keep chances
alive here and at this point we can
switch back to the non-engine view
the only way for black to keep chances
alive here
was I think to play the move King G7
weird looking move but you have to
defend the bishop
you have to defend the bishop
oh yeah just a boxing cage asks what
about Knight C6 Rook C7 Bishop F6
traveling traveling to d8 well here
there's a million things that white can
do there's literally so many moves that
white can play but the simplest is some
even Bishop H6 even Bishop Bishop D6 is
good
I mean there's just like 50 different
things that black can do
uh the the mythologies that y can do
so
can you tuck the bishop back to G7
unfortunately not the here there's the
move Knight B6
look at that Rook trap that's a a
concept that you have to be aware of
across so many different types of
openings this idea is missed by tons of
amazing but by tons of good players
for instance
it's totally different opening in the
king's Indian samish variation
there is a trap that involves the same
idea watch this bishop E3 Knight C6 this
is the Pono variation
very popular now in this position Rook
B8 was the classical move but a couple
of years ago Knight A5 got very popular
and I cannot tell you how many people
have walked into the strap Knight G3
and does anybody know what Black's best
move is what is the move that sets up
the Trap you can find this even if you
don't know anything about this position
B5 exactly and most people think oh
you're sacking your Pawn
but no this is not a sacrifice Knight B3
and black wins The Exchange
same concept
so anyways
I like drawing these parallels because
because I think it helps people remember
and of course this should be 797 King G7
and you pick up the Knight
so the only move was actually King G7
that's a very difficult move to play
that basically signals that you have
gone wrong because white has succeeded
in eliminating Black's strongest piece
you get the bishop pair you get some
initiative but the game is not over
black can try to unfurl untangle his
pieces and the game continues but I
think this is a skill that at this level
people still struggle with tremendously
like finding a good move after a blunder
or after a serious tactical mistake to
not collapse is quite difficult indeed
and that's exactly what black did
collapses immediately just gives up the
bishop with check and now we sneak the
Knight into E8 and the Knight will later
evacuate to one of these three squares
how do you not collapse after a blunder
well you just have to like assess the
damage
and you have to understand what the
actual threat is most people they they
see a move like Knight to five like oh
my god oh no I didn't see that I can
take the Rook
you know and then they just start
thinking in a disorganized fashion but
try to go through the normal process
what is the threat here well Knight
takes F6 is the first threat but there's
also these threats that you have to be
aware of
so you should conclude that you have to
keep in contact with the Rook whatever
you do that literally only leaves you
with one possible move
you can't move the bishop
so you have to defend the bishop and
there is only one piece capable of
defending the bishop and that is King G7
and by the way the whole point is that
here Knight B6 is no longer effective
because the Rook is still hanging
and moving The Rook would allow black to
address the threat of Knight B6
um and that's that's about it that was a
simple short game but
you know still shows us how effective
the Smith Mora still is at this level
I'll see you guys later thanks for
hanging out everybody hope you enjoyed
the match with alireza
and I'll see y'all later
[Music]